emigrate with each you alive band leader
record crisper brought in singer Frank
delay from the popular German reggae
band seed to amp up the vocals
this is the first single release of
their new album silent so long we
thought that this songs particularly
would describe kind of the record you
know it's kind of has a lot of melodies
in there it has a guest you know and
also has their to drive silence so long
is emigrate second LP the band brought
in a star-studded lineup for some cameo
appearances big-name guests include
shock rocker Marilyn Manson corns lead
singer Jonathan Davis Motorhead boss
Lemmy and electro clash singer features
okay here we go once again Casas very
pleased emigrates debut album was
recorded in the US but for this one
Ricard crispr brought the musicians to
Berlin Hey a city is alive it's
constituted by people the mentality are
totally different the rhythm the Bayeux
rhythm of the city is totally different
so impacts vary greatly the music or
whatever creation you're going to do our
always referred to first album as a New
York record as the second one is more
like a building record it's more Moody
it's more electro vibe
regarde prosper is internationally known
as Ram Stein's guitarist here on the
song if - dear babe but at the moment
Rammstein are on hiatus to take part in
other projects we have a policy in the
band of Ramzan that you know we tried to
make everyone comfortable as possible so
if we feel like you know there's too
much going on
people need to rest or people need to do
other things we try to listen to them
because in the end of the day it's more
important for us in Rammstein to keep
the band healthy and happy than just you
know follow idea of the industry
emigrate is cross the sideline launched
in 2005 he came up with the name because
he was living in New York at the time
it features an international cast and
English lyrics
in 2007 the debut album emigrate hit
number 8 in the German charts but
crispers not motivated by commercial
success emigrate started out of
frustration on my side Ram should always
get judged by the visuals rather than
the music and I felt somehow deep down
and myself I was I'm still a musician
and kind of had to prove that they also
can be judged by music only the cross /
emigrate is a chance to focus on
composing and producing they've never
played live on stage but some of the
band mates have mixed opinions the thing
is that I would definitely love to play
live because I think we can put up like
a great show and we have like a great
tracks to play live in my life is quite
complete right now with having two bands
I have the rumsen world where I can
perform thousands of people and I'm
quite happy with that and I have
emigrate as a musical output you know
when I can write songs and it really
concentrate on the music so the balance
of my life artistic artistically it's
quite cool for now there are no live
gigs in store but who knows next year
immigrant plans to release their third
album maybe they'll take that one on
tour
you